So, normally, oh, we gotta go back a second.
That healthy gut wall will keep things out.
However, when we eat additives, flavorings,
colorings, bad nutrition, eating junk food,
when we're exposed to high amounts of infectious organisms
like H. Pylor, right?
And other things, and we don't have
an adequate stomach acid to kill it,
it can damage those gut cells.
One of the worst things that damages that got cells
is genetically modified foods.
So genetically modified foods are huge killers
of gut cell gut wall cells.
That's how they work.
Well, we're gonna genetically modify this cord
so that it will be less prevalent
and less tasty to the cord borers
who decrease the cord production percentage by 10%.
What is it gonna do to the cord borers?
It's little worm.
Well, it's gonna destroy their gut.
They're gonna die and they won't want to eat this cord.
Well, that's a great idea.
What's it gonna do to our gut?
Oh, well, just forget about that.
So, we genetically modified food, it affects our gut.
It's one of the worst things that could affect our gut.
So, these gap junctions break down
and our cells become less healthy.
The cells, the individual epithelial cells of the gut
feed on a product called butyrate.
Butyrate is a product that of fermented undigested fiber.
So, normally if we're in a really good diet,
we're eating a lot of raw foods and such like that.
We have all this good undigestible fiber.
Breaks down to butyrate.
It feeds the gut cells really well
and the gut cells get all happy and healthy
and they start making a slime layer.
So, it's gross, but that's exactly
what your flora loves to live in.
So, that slime layer is a house for your flora.
So, you might have done this yourself
or you might know some friends that have done this.
I started taking probiotics because I heard those
were really good because that's really your gut flora.
So, I'm gonna start taking probiotics.
Good idea.
But if you don't have healthy epithelial cells,
producing a healthy slime layer,
there's no place for that probiotic to live
and you end up just wasting it.
And oh, I started taking probiotics.
It doesn't really help at all.
Well, step number one in healing your gut
might be changing your diet and eating better
and making sure that you're getting rid
of any noxious substance that's causing issues
like food sensitivities and chemicals
that you're eating, et cetera.
Step number two is maybe I'm gonna start taking a probiotic.
That would be a good idea.
Probably before step number two
would be starting to take a prebiotic.
So, a prebiotic is something that's going to produce
butylite, something that's gonna feed your intestinal cells
to get them healthy so that they can produce
this healthy slime layer so your probiotics can live there.
So, in the process of dealing with healing your gut,
then understand, well, I don't have a gut problem.
Well, if you have a health problem, I'll guarantee you,
you have a gut problem.
So, you just have to make this assumption
because we live in the world, in a fallen culture,
with all sorts of chemicals that we're exposed to
that our body was never supposed to be exposed to,
then we have issues.